you mentioned that you were surprised
how well that that one did a lot of
creators talk about getting depressed
when um
the videos don't do as well as they kind
of expect it there's the kind of feeling
you can get really worn out by that dude
yeah
um you do your yourself feel that and
also do you have advice for others that
feel this
um yeah it's weird because I am a
numbers guy but also it it used to it
used to very much especially when I was
like betting everything I had on a video
when it did bad that was devastating I'd
cry and I'd be depressed for days and it
really would have a severe impact on my
mood but I don't know now it doesn't
really matter it's uh for video does
better just look at it and I'm like oh
why'd this video do bad uh probably oh
there's a little retention dip there I
don't think people like the thumbnail
maybe we should switch it I just look at
it objectively unemotional and then just
move on and I feel like that's a much
healthier way of going about it so if a
Creator is listening like that is the
ideal way to
um respond to a video that's doing bad
just remove emotion from the equation
and just look at it and figure out how
you can visit the next one is there
tricks to being able to detach yourself
from the from that because because like
in your case I mean that's true for
creators but in your case
this this is like a lot of money on the
line yeah one this video is called my
life yeah so much time but no I mean you
just I mean I don't know the only real
answer is it's just the conscious effort
you just have to unemotionally look at
the video determine the problems and
then move on like there's there is no
secret you know what I mean it's just
that's it's that and if you really can't
bring yourself to do it then you're just
screwed honestly maybe you're not meant
for this game
okay so that's part of the development
as the Creator is like being able to be
a different longevity yes yeah you have
to unemotionally be able to look at
videos that flop and figure it out uh
because if not just getting you can not
every video can be a one out of ten and
so when a video does bad you know that
that just stress and depression it's
just gonna eventually get to you in the
long run so you said you've uh failed in
a bunch of videos
uh sort of taking them to completion so
what are some of the biggest fails yeah
weirdly enough as we've matured and
we've done this one we don't have that
problem as much especially that we're
getting into the multi-million dollar
budgets per video it's like failure is
not really an option anymore so I'm a
little more particular about what I do
but back in the day yeah like we would
do a video where we spent 24 hours on a
dessert Island and uh we filmed it did
it all and I just I didn't like it after
the edit so I just grabbed the voice and
we went back to the deserted island and
spent another 24 hours there and
refilmed it
um or uh could that have been caught and
prevented at the idea stage like where
like no it's a good idea it was just
poor execution to be honest when we were
out there it was hot we were we're just
like we all at one point just kind of
wanted to die it was just miserable so
how do how do you avoid that these days
uh well I just wanted a little cooler to
be honest and then we had literally the
amount of fun we had in the video was
like 10 times higher oh interesting so
you like there's some practical details
that you just learned yeah I know what
it takes videos that where it's very hot
or or it's on water because I get super
seasick it's like a kind of like 10
things that if they have these variables
I'm down to do it but my fun meter is
not as high as normal uh like we tried
to
um anytime we do anything on a boat like
when we spent 24 hours in a pyramid or
triangle or when I tried to spend like
which I didn't get up but I try to spend
like 100 hours at sea or whatever just
like on a raft it's just like I it makes
me want to throw up and I get so seasick
I can't even see straight but there are
just some videos that require me to be
on a boat so I just suck it up
um so when you spend months in creating
a video I know this is probably
stressful to some creators uh like how
much stress how do you feel when you
have to click publish uh video now not
much you're able to detach yourself yeah
again in Old me tons I mean I'd be like
scratching and nervous and like my hands
would be sweating like to the point
where I'm almost about to puke I'm like
I really hope people like this but you
know I don't know I think that's just
part of maturing it there's different
and as a content creator there's
different phases and uh you just like
once you get over the the fear that
you're just gonna wake up one day and be
irrelevant you know and you just you
know accept that like you believe in
yourself and you believe in your content
and that you can continue to be relevant
then you don't I don't know you kind of
are it's a little bit easier to attach
yourself I guess and that's I it's a
much healthier place to be you can't do
this for 10 years if every little thing
just causes these huge emotional
reactions it's like that's why a lot of
creators go a little you know mentally
insane you know you have to get out of
that that game because it really messes
with you we've talked about this a
little bit but how do you define and how
do you suggest others define success
some people success is retiring their
mom literally you know for you finances
inspiring people and educating them and
you know whatever they're peeking their
curiosity
um for other people it's just quitting
their job you have to self-reflect on
what your definition of success is
because I think a lot of creators kind
of don't really think don't introspect
like they kind of want to keep getting
more and more subscribers kind of thing
and yeah but subscribers is just a
vanity metric you know it doesn't
subscribers don't correlate to views
sure or views what yeah I know but
that's more that was a drag to you that
was more direct to people listening
because uh a lot of people do really
care about subscribers or even followers
like on Tick Tock but if you look like
your view if on YouTube very very few
percent if even a percent of your views
come from the sub feed right you know
they're almost all home feeders
suggested what's the last time you
clicked on your sub feed to watch a
video oh almost never yeah yeah maybe
five years ago it used to be a thing
it's not anymore no one does
um and it's getting harder and harder to
find this I subscribe to way too many
channels I think yeah that's what
everyone does and you subscribe to 10
channels they're great but two years
later your taste evolves and it's like
it's a mess and so
um subscribers don't really matter
followers on Tick Tock don't really
matter
um so anyways it really they really are
the definition of a vanity metric and
but what about views they do obviously
because if people are showing up time
and time again that's what matters okay
so that
that's a good thing to uh Define a
success I just feel like um that too can
be a problem
because uh
I would say you know if I wanted to be
successful like it's a young Creator I
might start copying Mr Beast or
something like that right yeah like
there's you start trying to take
shortcuts as opposed to find your your
own unique voice right so like chasing
views is a problem too it feels like or
no
um it's as long as you detach yourself
from that I mean if you're sounds like
if you're lazy yeah and you just want to
copy someone else and not experiment and
find your own way but yeah I mean you
can't make that excuse for them and
someone just
isn't coming up with original stuff and
putting in the effort you can't just say
oh it's because they're chasing views we
need some different metric from the
chase no they just need to find their
own way well it just feels like unique
type of content will often lead to
sacrifice in the number of views in the
short term by the long term you win
okay or if you do win you you win more I
guess would be a better way putting it